[Musik]
gut wir haben heute Dienst am Montag
Freitag ist es alles rosa also chill ja
fünf Tage später fünf Tage lang mussten
die Regale von vanille-gelb auf rosa
gesprüht werden das hat uns nicht nur
viel Geld gekostet sondern auch sehr
viel Zeit ich finde das dieser Zeit
Faktor hat auch noch mal richtig schlimm
gemacht ich habe sie gesagt ich wollte
ich habe die Verantwortung
hättest du auch mal richtig deine
Meinung durchdringen und nicht nur
einmal sagen okay könnten wir ja
eigentlich rosa machen ich glaube jeder
Mann kann mich jetzt gerade verstehen
[Musik]
so dann wurden ja den neolithplatten
eingebaut diese Natursteinplatten die
habe ich ja auch bei mir im coffee
corner zu Hause und das krasse ist also
der Ruhrpark bzw Storm Café sind der
wirklich ist unser zweites Zuhause
geworden in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten und es spiegelt sich halt schon
sehr viel wieder
in diesen zwei Monaten
nach Hause gekommen ne das hat sich ja
gar nicht mehr gelogen
und ich wollte unbedingt dieses Abu
Dhabi silk haben das ist so nennt sich
das Design was ich da habe und ich finde
da an dem Tag war auch noch mal so wow
war die richtige Entscheidung
[Musik]
so und dann kam die betriebsurlaubswelle
mit der wir gar nicht gerechnet haben
ich meine wir waren voll in unserem
Elementen für uns gab es nur storencafé
wir müssen jeden Tag vorankommen und
dann hat der Steinmetz gesagt also die
die neoli Platten schaffe ich jetzt
nicht mehr wir haben noch Betriebsurlaub
alle keine arbeitet von uns die nächste
Woche und wir sind nein das versteht
sich alles nach hinten dass ich paar
Sachen verschoben habe hat sich diese
eine Baustein auch verschoben und dann
ist alles nach hinten geschoben worden
dass wir gar keine Zeitgefühl mehr
hatten das war eine richtige
Kettenreaktion ne welcher Tag war und ja
wirklich wir wissen teilweise eigentlich
welcher Wochentag ist das und die der
Tag geht gefühlt auch mal viel zu
schnell rum wir sind jeden Tag erst um 3
Uhr im Bett stehen morgens um 8 Uhr
wieder auf und äh deswegen ja haben die
Leute Betriebsurlaub im Sommer aber dann
kam der Kevin raus an Dich wirklich
Props gehen du kriegst Familie rosane
Karte du kannst Bubble Boys bis zum
Abwinken kannst Sebastian bisschen
ablenken du hast ein Leben lang ein gut
bei mir wenn du das gerade siehst
und ihr könnt nur zusammensetzen und
verkleben wenn was fertig ist mit dem
Verkleben das würden wir tatsächlich
auch hinbekommen okay aber bringt nichts
wenn die Platten nicht zugeschnitten
sind
kommen wir da auch nicht weiter also
hier steht ja dann schon alles das heißt
hier kann die Einarbeitung beginnen
drüben wäre super wenn die Kasse fertig
ist Kasse und eventuell diese Pyramide
es geht ja glaube ich auch schnell ich
glaube das ist keine große arbeiten
und das Verkleben machen wenn die Zeit
haben
[Musik]
ja wolle weg mit der grünen Folie
auf Nimmerwiedersehen weg
[Musik]
bist du bereit kurz einkaufen ne weißt
du die Lampen aussieht ich habe die
Lampen eingebaut
boah richtig schön kaltweiß acht Ringe
sind für unsere acht Säulen unsere
Küchentischen Philosophie nee Herr der
Ringe
die beste Entscheidung die man machen
konnte Feierabend
bei Media Markt gearbeitet es gibt
einfach ran und die Geräte macht einfach
leiser einfach leiser
[Musik]
also ich muss euch jetzt nur noch
Tortenringe verkaufen dann ist alles gut
für diesen Streit den ich nicht
vergessen würde den einen Abend
mega so und jetzt habe ich meine Frage
wer hatte recht mega scheiße
und die sehen richtig toll aus so
richtig hochwertig sein auch sehr sehr
hochwertig ja
warte mal heißt es jetzt was ich
entscheide ob es bleibt oder nicht ja ja
krass ich darf entscheiden wie das hier
gleich aussieht es geht um die Decke die
Decke da gibt's die Option entweder mit
Unkraut oder ohne Unkraut mit Unkraut
Blumen irgendwelche Blumen so hier haben
wir den Teil ohne und hier mit
gewonnen hat
[Musik]
die neue Haselnusscreme von Kiki jetzt
bei Kaufland darf man das sagen mit
Käfer geworden
bist du wirklich mit oder ohne sei
ehrlich komplett ehrlich bin komplett
ich glaube nicht rein tun die ganze
Spannung für eine Fake Entscheidung
wieder
[Musik]
eine Fummelarbeit ist
ja danke sehr schon Mann
so dann haben wir die blumendecke
aufgehangen bzw was hast blumendecke wir
haben jede Blume einzeln den Stil
geknickt und dann dieses Gitter und
überhaupt auf die Idee zu kommen mit dem
Gitter mit dem gucken was es im Baumarkt
eigentlich für Möglichkeiten gibt
ja wirklich das ist das Auto dadurch
durch die Gitter und so weiter richtig
gelitten aber es hat sich gelohnt drei
Tage lang haben wir mit der Kiki Crew
die Blumenladen die Decke geheim
teilweise auch Leute aus dem Onlineshop
abgezogen teilweise haben sich auch voll
viele Freiwillige angeboten um sein
echte mit aufhängen die Blumen und ich
denke so
ja gerne diese Gitter kaufen im Bauhaus
ne und ich habe mir einen normalen Auto
gefahren also mit dieser kleinen
Limousine die C-Klasse und ich bin dahin
gefahren und ich schwör's dir Kiki ich
fahre mit dem Gitter da ob sie kauft
steht vom Auto wie passt das jetzt hier
rein
ich schwöre ich schwöre eine Stunde lang
habe ich sowas reinzupacken ich habe am
schwitzen 30 Grad alles was ich bin
gestorben bis ich gesagt habe weißt du
was ich gehe jetzt da rein in den
Baumarkt hol mir so ein Knipser und
knipse sie selber ab und hat ja
reingepackt hast du die halbiert
dürfen nur um 22 Uhr noch in der
Backstube rum experimentieren eigentlich
voll der Kindheitstraum also wir haben
einen neuen Backofen gekauft extra für
das Café Projekt weil alle bisherigen
Backofen in der Backstube haben nicht
zum perfekten Sebastian Cheesecake
Ergebnis geführt so und dann haben wir
angefangen auszutesten und ich habe ganz
viele Nachrichten über Instagram
bekommen weil Herr dein Rezept steht
doch schon was warum probierst du jede
Nacht bis 3 Uhr morgens äh dann kannst
du was mit dem Ofen ist noch mal eine
ganz andere Nummer das perfekte Ergebnis
und keiner hat so wirklich hinbekommen
wie Du es möchtest und da habe ich eine
Kiki mach doch einfach selber mach
selber und dann zeigst du es den Leuten
und gut ist es ist ja nicht überheblich
oder so es ist für die die verkaufen ja
sowas auch gar nicht sein normal es ist
auch gegen jede Regel ein Meister
Konditor sagt der bescheuert dass du was
willst du den Kuchen verbrennen oder
warum ist der innen noch so cremig da
muss doch total fest sein oder da müssen
Mürbeteig drunter und da müssen die
Meister Konditoren alle mit denen ich
Kontakt hatte die haben es nicht
nicht so ganz hinbekommen was überhaupt
nicht daran liegt dass die keine
Expertise haben sondern weil für diesen
Kuchen muss man alle Regeln beiseite
legen und haben gesagt nicht wirklich du
hast mich wirklich gezwungen selber da
rumzuprobieren drum zu testen so das
Ding ist der ist ein viel viel größer
als in meinem Youtube-Video und viel
viel höher weil ich auch möchte dass ein
wenn ein Gast bei uns bestellt dass er
dieses dieses runterschaben nicht nur in
so einem dünn Stück Kuchen macht oder so
sondern das muss schon das muss schon
massig sein und Handy sein genau und äh
das wollte ich einfach damit irgendwie
kreieren und dann noch verschiedene
Varianten und dann haben wir noch
Erdbeeren und Schoko ausprobiert und
nach etlichen Nächten in der Backstube
hat das auch funktioniert die Rezeptur
gebe ich jetzt an die Meister Konditoren
weiter und die können dann nach meiner
Rezeptur das ganze backen
ich schwöre euch beim Schwitzen Alter du
bist so im Ofen drin
[Musik]
Meister Konditor Hamza
1 Uhr morgens in der Backstube
schön verbrannt superbrannt weiß nicht
so schlimm ich finde es gar nicht so
schlimm ich finde es geht noch ist cool
da gibt es bestanden aber oben zu dunkel
also wir haben ein falsches Gerät
gekauft ist leider sehr gut gegangen mit
dem Gerät und deswegen haben wir jetzt
hier
Experten am Werk
Espresso perfecto
aber was ein Arsch
ja und dann machst du ja und jetzt so
super schön
[Musik]
mega mega schön
oh
ja nein
und dann Angst zu haben einer 45 gehe
ich einer von 40 hat sich gelohnt
hat
Scheiße
unser Mitarbeiter des Monats ich arbeite
nicht aber
von der anderen Seite mega das müssen
wir als Merch rausbringen
[Musik]
ja ja am Arbeiten
ich erzähle euch mal was von Bernhard
kleinanteil vor drei Jahren
kennengelernt und weißt du wisst ihr wie
ihr kennengelernt haben
genauso immer lächeln
Feinarbeit hier guck mal wie sauber das
ist was ist alles passiert wir sind hier
ein ganzes Stück vorangekommen danke
Team Wallach ohne die werden wir nämlich
komplett verloren ja die Maschine nehmen
extra austauschen lassen kommt das ganze
Crash Eis raus
hier hat irgendjemand von uns Mist
gebaut wir streiten uns ob du das was
haben soll oder ich die zu klein das ist
eine dicke Lücke drin ich bin der
Meinung ne also ich war hier mit Kevin
hier Kevin
also
gemerkt und hat Benny gesagt äh Kevin
gesagt hey irgendwas und dann haben wir
ein bisschen gefroren und erst auf die
Idee gekommen ja das Kriege schon
irgendwie so eine Schüssel Markus macht
das schon irgendwie genau Markus
Silikon aber aber die Idee war gut egal
wie das war kommen
[Musik]
Video online gegangen
weißt du noch entspannt
das geht nicht das geht das geht nicht
unser blumenmädchen
[Musik]
Bernhard das sieht so gut dass es mich
noch mal aufnehmen
[Musik]
ist ein guter Freund von mir
ich stelle mir auch immer die Cabrio
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
das ist toll
das sieht aus original wie diese 3D
Grafik ja was im Urlaub zurück im ganzen
Land hat sich verändert das auch richtig
gut ich finde es schön ich bleib hier
das sagt jeder der reinkommt sagt die
Lampen sind geil
beim Reinkommen ich habe es auch nicht
gemerkt ja noch davor oh mein Foto toll
ist das mit dem Neon warum wir da Platz
gelassen haben
[Musik]
sondern nur dass man sieht was hier
gerade macht
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt hier die Bazooka sauber
das sind so teile wo unsere Cremes
reinkommen und womit wir dann diese
Bubble Balls befüllen
[Musik]
also rituals
ich habe gedacht es ist jetzt kommen wir
haben die jetzt gefilmt wir haben noch
ein bisschen bescheuert ne weil die
waren auch nicht so aber jetzt haben wir
das Problem dass es einfach hier ein
bisschen weniger
zu schwer sind
andererseits brauchen wir aber so viel
Platz für die Gläser weil die
wahrscheinlich sehr schnell verkauft
werden also das machen wir rufen wir den
Markus fragen ob du eine Lösung hat
aber das riesenregal ne das ist das
lange Regal und da sind jetzt auch die
schweren cremegläser drin
wir haben gedacht das ist so das
Steckenpferd dann ist eine ganze Creme
Ecke noch eine Überlegung aber das ist
die Frage ob das dann nur bei einem
Regal machen ob wir aus dem gleichen
Material quasi noch mal wie eine Blende
bauen die wir dann quer hier drunter
setzen weil wenn jetzt ein Holz hast was
was so ist z.B das kannst Du so ja nicht
so biegen und dann kann man es
vielleicht ein bisschen noch mal stützen
wenn wir dann hier mit aber du hast halt
so eine Blende dann hier drin okay
schon extrem und das sollte doppelt so
viel drauf also ein längeres Regal ja
immer das lange und das hingegen das ist
super doppelt
schon viel Produkt
wir machen das am stützen wir das einmal
dann kann man das mal probieren was
anderes fällt mir jetzt auch nicht ein
sonst ja ich würde es erstmal probieren
mit so einer Blende damit du die ganze
Fläche hast wenn das nicht geht müssen
wir so dazwischen sollte machen
[Musik]
boah ich finde es mega
ganz lecker das freut uns natürlich der
San Sebastian ist gut
wow endlich aber nicht mit Liebe aber
guck mal bitte schön Karamell Eis
Macchiato Hefe dich auch cool danke
schön danke für den Einsatz Leute aber
du bist ein bisschen glaube ich vorher
weiß ich habe das denn ich wollte diesen
Effekt haben Kaffee und so weiter genau
bezahlen okay not macht erfinderisch
ich halte das geht an dich
[Musik]
zu traurig ein
wir sind richtig müde
wir hatten ganz viele Schulungen es gibt
ja nicht nur die Schulungen von unseren
Produkten im Bereich Backen und Kochen
es gibt dann natürlich auch noch eine
technische Schulung für die Kasse etc
und was du nicht ganz ganz wichtig war
aber eine bio-schulung wir sind der
bio-zertifiziert wir haben sehr viele
Bio-Produkte und es gibt halt Bio und
Bio und es gibt halt wirklich super
viele Unterschiede und ich wollte dass
jedes neue Mitglied das auch kennt also
jeder gut beraten kann und weiß okay
warum ist jetzt unser Kurkuma Extrakt
anders als das was man vielleicht im
Supermarkt bekommt oder so also das war
mir ganz wichtig diese Schulung hat
viereinhalb Stunden gedauert und ich
denke das war auch super lehrreich und
wir haben eine die Lena ganz liebe Grüße
an dich an der Stelle hat alles
mitgeschrieben und sie hat ein richtiges
Buch gemacht und das werde ich
ausdrucken und auf jeden Fall noch mal
da hinlegen das ist der Hammer
unsere Bubble Balls wir haben uns
gedacht okay die Leute erwarten jetzt
von mir dass ich einfach eine
Kuchentheke habe mit verschiedenen
Küchlein und Kaffeegetränke und wir
haben gesagt nein wir machen Bubble
Balls was sind Bubble Balls das sind
richtig leckere frittierte Teigbällchen
die in total fluffy sind und außen
leicht kross und nicht zu groß was ist
da für Unterschiede gibt man muss
teilweise schauen welches es gibt
Unterschiede beim Frittieröl da hast du
dich auch richtig mit befasst ne je
nachdem welches Öl du verwendest gibt's
immer eine andere
ja wirklich also wir haben mit
verschiedenen Ölen die Bubble Boards aus
frittiert und das coole ist die werden
befüllt nicht mit x beliebigen Cremes
sondern mit unseren creams
[Musik]
das aller krasseste ist ja das Packaging
das ist ja das aller das ist das aller
krasseste es ist einfach eine
Pralinenschachtel einfach ein Geschenk
an sich selbst das erwartet man
eigentlich gar nicht weil so frittiertem
Gebäck ne aber wir haben gesagt nee wir
setzen noch mal einen drauf und Achtung
geil
glücklich ne
boah das riecht extrem ne oh mein Gott
[Musik]
den wunderschönen rund bekommen es ist
also es ist halt so eine Maschine die
ist auch extra dafür konzipiert bzw mehr
oder weniger aber es ist halt unsere
eigene Mischung und die jetzt Kreis
rumzukriegen das war schon eine
Wissenschaft Gesicht
[Musik]
ja als du es gesagt hast habe ich hier
so ein Kribbeln bekommen Angst und
Paniken
weil er muss auch allen 22 neuen Kuh
Mitgliedern die Kasse erklären und du
musst auf jede Frage bewaffnet sein ich
könnte meinen Druck verstehen ich weiß
wofür ich Angst habe meine größte Angst
ist dass wir einfach ausverkauft sind
dass die Leute so um 18 Uhr lang gehen
und sind die Hälfte Laden schon weg so
ja das kann natürlich auch passieren
aber auch irgendwie ich würde es schade
finden dass Leute die dann nach der
Arbeit kommen sagen wofür bin ich jetzt
hier angehalten für Leute die auch die
uns gar nicht kennen und sagen dann um
18 Uhr kommen
das ist nicht nur die Community die uns
besuchen kommt die kann vielleicht okay
da kam der Ansturm aber neue Leute die
sich denken Kikis kitchen was ist das
denn da voll unprofessionell was sie
daheim stehen
Kaffee fällt runter oder so und das ist
komplett neuer Kunde jetzt gar nicht
kenne das sind für Leute
richtig stolz auf die Crew die die neue
im Onlineshop sowieso die rocken das
aber jetzt gerade die neue Kiki Crew im
Ruhrpark boah die geben sich so viel
Müll auch bei den Schulungen und so die
sind voll dabei mit Herz und freuen sich
auch richtig
ey Leute komm vorbei guckt euch diese
actions an das müsst ihr sehen ohne Spaß
[Gelächter]
Alter
unglaublich aus wirklich
das Denken
[Musik]